hello my name is
supporting teachers in history and Latin
instruction and this presentation here
is on teaching history classically and
that's going to be focus on lesson
crafting so I wanted to begin with three
reminders from the earlier video on on
history in the Classical Academy and
just to just to get our bearings and
make sure that we're on the same page
and a lot of the things that are a
little bit more practical in this video
well will be based on the ideas that
were expounded in the first one so three
brief reminders here the first of which
was our understanding of what history is
that history is a true story a true
story of human beings right about their
thoughts and their actions and as we're
counted through the centuries so we want
to keep in mind that story elements to
to history also have a reminder of who
the history teacher is that history
teacher is not google or encyclopedia is
certainly not an ideologue and to
correct misconceptions about what
classical education is it's also not a
he's also not a long winded lecture he
said he's a storyteller he or she is a
storyteller when they are teaching
history and then finally the four
elements of history of excellent history
instruction storytelling places and
dates primary texts and Socratic
questioning many of these will come up
in the course of this this presentation
here though not necessarily in that in
that order so just with those three pre
three reviews from our reminders from
the first presentation in our minds I
like to look forward to to what we'll be
talking about next and provide a little
bit of a preview here
this presentation will have three parts
the part one is warning about what not
to do
what we probably won't be seeing very
much of in a classical
Kadim II in classical history lesson and
some things to avoid in the process
oftentimes they can be highly clarifying
to know what what things not to do but
then we're gonna shift on over and start
looking at kind of what you're going to
be doing the night before a lesson and
then in crafting the lesson itself in
part 2 and then what's actually
happening in the classroom what's
actually happening when you're
performing the lesson in front of the
class and the goal here is not
necessarily here's the way to do it from
Hillsdale these are not mandates these
are not the only way you know but these
tend to be things that from my own
experience from the experience of
veteran BCS I teachers that this that
this is these are good ways to go about
planning history but it is the start of
a conversation a conversation amongst
teachers and about how to do this do
this well for the most students and so I
want to keep in mind that this is the
goal here is to gain a lay of the land
as it were it's gaining an understanding
of of what of some things to to navigate
and chart and and and might inform your
own your instruction and planning so
let's just dive on in part one here what
not to do and I think there are the
first way we can think about things that
we might probably want to avoid is think
about things that we can just almost
completely take off the table see you
say that phrase okay so what can we take
off the table okay well first of all
let's we'd like to avoid reducing
everything to mere social studies that
doesn't mean that there aren't cultural
studies that we don't think about large
groups of people or or some of the
reasons why they might act as in the
aggregate but it's certainly not going
to be driving us our studies and we
don't want to reduce history to a social
studies class okay so we want to avoid
this more scientific
a set of factors that are that move a
human behavior and we want to go beyond
it just being a study of different
cultures second we certainly want to
avoid ideology this there's it's
disingenuous for teachers or a school to
to present historical events or ideas
through one lens you know it's we do not
have a we want to call things as they
are and let them stand as they are and
let students wrestle with them as they
are right and we know there is simply
the belief that we we can we can find a
truth in this and and what's good and
what's bad and we can do that by showing
allowing students to do that mental work
to arrive at those things so we do not
want to cast any things in a particular
particular light or ideology um likewise
we don't want to go we want to go past
the mere facts or information the class
that gets up there and yeah this that
typical idea of the students brain you
screw off the cranium and you just put
different items in there for them to
know okay no we want to go beyond the
facts and information they they have to
use or in that you can't dive deeper
into something unless you know the those
basic tenets but but that's that's not
all there is to it um next we also want
to avoid learning that is driven
exclusively by student research current
events or personal interest and in the
course of this presentation I'll touch
on each of those and why we why those
aren't the things that we want to to be
to be using to to engage students and
what we should be using instead we also
want to avoid this idea of a curriculum
in a box or a canned curriculum a lot of
programs especially in social studies
nowadays the teacher doesn't necessarily
have to know the content that they're
teaching but they just need to know how
to deliver it
and oftentimes that means that the
curriculum has all planned out for the
teacher with step-by-step directions and
a script to read and to show them this
picture and talk about this thing now
and and we want to go beyond that we
want teachers across the curriculum to
take ownership of the things that
they're teaching that first involves
them knowing learning and knowing their
content and then figure out the best
ways to share that with their students
all right so we want to avoid those
types of things students are
particularly sensitive to scripts they
can sense a script
it feels inauthentic to them you know
they they don't trust that the teacher
actually knows what they're what they're
teaching and so it's it's very important
that we try to avoid curriculum in the
box or cane curricula we also want to
avoid busy work there's no time in a
classical curriculum that there's any
that there should be any space for busy
work that we just need to have something
to put in the grade book or to use up
time in the classroom or because it's
supposed to be a quote quote rigorous
and they and so therefore there there
ought to be homework that we just have
to give them something no we don't want
that it needs to be purposeful it needs
to help student understanding you know
it should be aimed at that at that goal
okay so we don't want to do just busy
work
and lastly ironically we don't want to
do death by a PowerPoint what's the
difference here between I've been doing
and in the classroom is that this is a
presentation to adults on specific how
to do certain things or some reflections
and certainly providing considerably
more than just on the powerpoints
inquests the story is too organic it's
too it's too it's too special to reduce
merely to a number of slides with notes
on them okay
there's ways to incorporate some things
well powerpoints work well with images
as we'll discuss later but we don't want
to put the notes up on the board as it
were and read through them and have them
just copying down for made him like that
we wanted to flow out of the story and
to follow the story and so those are
some things that we can
we should avoid and that we can by and
large take off the table as they're not
going to enter into our our repertoire
of tools that we can use to to teach
this curriculum okay there's some other
things that while while we don't
necessarily need to get rid of them we
can make rare okay there's there may be
a time in place for these but it's
probably far less often than a lot of
contemporary classrooms I will have what
you would see in its contemporary
classroom okay so what are these things
up for one group work doesn't mean that
there aren't certain situations for them
but I think it's fairly rare and with
all the with group work and all these
things that were that I'm going to share
here
it's just raising the bar all right
again we want to make the best use of
students time we want them to engage
with the material we want them to
understand it to go deeper okay and if
it's not if these things aren't doing
that then we shouldn't we shouldn't
employ them but if they are helpful then
there's an opening there right away
which the if it's if it's cert if it
teaches something in a way which a
teacher cannot replicate themselves and
they're in their storytelling then that
may be an occasion form but in general
group work is something that we that
will be rare as will be in class
assignments particularly of the sort in
which the teacher is not engaging
students it's there's actually some good
research to show that assignments being
done in the classroom in the class
interspersed with instruction are
helpful so long as the teacher is
engaging with students and walking
around and figuring out where students
are getting tripped up and and working
with them and then realizing a certain
point hey we need to actually reteach
this whole thing or treat this as a
whole class again because so many
students aren't quite understanding it
okay so in class assignments especially
those without teacher engagement
projects projects video and you know
again just raising the bar there is
something projects and videos that
actually help with soo
understanding but there are many that
there are not ants more of a fun thing
to do okay well that's fine but is it
helping them ward because they're really
helping the more in a unique way that
the teacher could not replicate and
through there's no telling of the story
and then finally something we want to
make prayer is just canned worksheets
and tests there if something is good and
it's helpful and it helps students or
and we should use it okay that's our
standard and there are things are
already prepared that they can be very
helpful or have helpful elements in them
but we probably don't want to use them
without reviewing them without
critiquing them without holding a
discursive eye towards them all right we
want pull the things they're good leave
the things they're not and improve them
right so you know this is kind of going
along with a canned curriculum there are
worksheets and tests and that's that's
quite all right but let's make sure that
they are really helping students to
learn okay and that's just busywork or a
fun merely a fun activity all right so
now that we've cleared off the table
some of the things that we won't be
looking at I won't be looking at very
often and you won't see be using in your
teaching certainly on a daily basis
let's let's begin looking at part two
right crafting the lesson and bear in
mind that these ideas of storytelling
places and dates in primary text the
Socratic questioning you're all going to
be here and they're just gonna be in
different orders and stuff like that all
right so the the phrase that was used
here is crafting the lesson and that
that word has chosen intentionally let's
look at what our goal is and how we will
reach it every every subject that a
teacher shares with students it has
teacher ownership in it and a lot of
work is being done in order to to form
and prepare for that history in a unique
way
however I believe it has has certain
challenges to it that some of the other
subjects do not
and this is the fact that there are so
many judgment calls that each teacher
has to make while crafting a lesson
while planning it right for one the
sheer quantity of material that a
teacher could cover with students is
enormous it can always keep going deeper
and deeper and add more details to a
story into a history lesson right but
there's a certain point where we have to
you know cut cut ourselves off and say
that this is this is sufficient this is
what's going to be appropriate for this
situation not to mention that there are
so many things that you have to then
decide are going to be employed in
crafting a story yeah in in composition
in writing many of the greatest writers
of all time talk about how challenging
it is to to write well right it's this
it's a sister II is telling a story it's
a similar situation in history and when
we craft so so what what is this here
okay storytelling in history is an art
and therefore history lesson the history
lesson is a work of craftsmanship and
one of you teachers as craftsmen in
history class so the art so what is
exactly the art what are we where are we
providing to students here well the
phrase that that we can use is that we
are the art is one of re presenting past
presence okay which is a little bit of
tongue twister but let's parse this out
a little bit okay so um and this is this
goes back to that that idea that we
don't really want lessons to be driven
by current infants now of course
students always clamoring for curve
that's why can we learn about the things
that are going around around us today
they're relevant to they're happening
they're alive for us okay well one of
the things that we can point out to them
is that look that what we were learning
about was also a Korean event at a
certain time to a certain group of
people
this was their current event they were
in it and so our job as teachers of
history
is to take that past event okay that
past event that was taking place in the
present time for them was a current
event for them and make it present again
to our students we want our students to
engage the past events as though they
were current events okay so we want to
represent and remake present okay the
presence of the past or the past
presence all right all right we want to
take those old old events and make them
current okay or in or perhaps better way
of putting this is taking the student in
transporting them to that world
to that time in place into those events
they're about to unfold okay so that's
that's the art that's that's what every
history lesson is attempting to to do
right and in doing so we can try to
achieve our goal and it's the same goal
I believe in every subject and that's
experiences of wonder okay now wonder is
a word that is tossed around quite
frequently nowadays and if we want to
consider but it has a very long
tradition to it right wonder is a it's
actually a species of fear it's a type
of fear it but it's a it's a joyful fear
it comes from when we've come across
something and we understand or see the
reality of it for the first time in such
a way that one we were we find it
incredible right almost paralyzing him
up ourselves but also it's a little
fearful we have a little fear that how
did I not know this up to this point
okay and what else don't I know one what
else might this mean okay so we start
asking yourself these questions okay and
why does wonder this type of joyful fear
what role does it play in education
right
okay well consider what Plato says in
this Phaedrus that wisdom begins in
wonder okay all learning all knowledge
okay all education begins and wonder
it's in that act of wonder okay or that
that experience of wonder okay that
warning takes place and it students are
inspired to learn more it's in those
moments that they they have that
yearning and the desire to know the
aerosol talks about is alive and
awakened okay and propels one into a
love of learning right and this is in
the tradition this is commonly they
refer to the Stars okay the stars as
Wonder right and looking at them and
wonder right and and what hard they what
what's the relationship between the
heavens it in my my own little existence
what else is out there all of these
things come into play into play with
wonder okay and so in history we want to
make these past current events present
to students again so that they can
experience Wonder in them and you can't
force it on them students have to
experience for yourself we can just do
everything we can't to situate things
well for them okay and then when they
have those moments of wonder the only do
they have insights into things but
they're driven to learn more and to love
learning so that is our goal and our
arts and our goal in crafting these
lessons all right so let's look at how
we're going to represent things past
okay and so that so we can allow for
experiences of wonder in our lessons so
crafting the lesson there's two steps
two steps to crafting the lesson and
this is obviously before we go into the
classroom okay step one warning and
knowing the story yourself that
experience of wonder is impossible for
students to have especially about things
that are being shared with them through
a teacher without the teacher first
knowing or learning knowing and
wondering at this
same content themselves it's impossible
okay if the heart of Education here if
the education educating act is a [ __ ] is
is this moment of wonder then what
brings that about well it's this the
teacher having wondered at first and I
can only wonder if they learn and they
know it and then they take that that the
teacher has to have two loves right
the teacher has one love for their
students and one love for their subject
matter for their content okay right and
the teacher wants to share that love
that they have of their subject matter
with the student whom they love okay
only care for out of an act of love that
sharing of this of how wonderful this
content is and what this thing the
subject I love with the student okay
that's that's where education takes
place and that happens around by
allowing this experience of wonder and
the student but that's impossible that
the teacher can't share that wonder or
nor know how to set things up for the
experience of wonder with the student if
they've never learned and know it
themselves and having wondered that
right so the first step in crafting a
lessons for the teacher to learn and to
know the story him or herself um how is
this done well briefly the Barney
charter school initiative has a k12
program guide and that is essentially
the the curriculum that be si si schools
use okay this lays out the things that
students should have an encounter with
in each year and then from there there's
a series of student texts and so the
teacher should read the program guide
they should read the student text to
find out what the students will be
reading okay on grades three through six
these are student readers and grades
seven through twelve these are these are
these are textbooks of some sort or
histories and in grades K through two
and there's a series of things that you
would that the teacher reads aloud to
the students okay so we read those first
on our own okay if you haven't if this
is new to you the
think content is in there they enjoy it
okay step into it can you learn yourself
okay from there we can determine our
pacing though you know there's some what
steps that we can teach we let how much
what we have to cover in a year
determine the rate at which we remove an
amount of details that we include okay
and while we're reading these student
texts and looking through the program
guide in learning ourselves we're
constantly asking ourselves what
surprised me what did I wonder at have a
disposition towards wondering at these
things and in the what your interest
lead you and from there we move over
into research okay this this first step
of crafting the lesson learning the
story and then knowing the story of
yourself yeah that involves one reading
what the students are reading that gets
our our baseline and then we do go and
do some research now B si si has done a
lot of work with Hillsdale College
faculty and with veteran be si si
teachers to review hundreds of different
resources and books that are in print
and available accurate well-written for
the younger kids well illustrated okay
and these books are there and they're in
the program guide at the beginning of
the history chapters and they're there
for you to to have at your disposal to
help to help do your research so you
don't necessarily have to go digging a
lot right off the bat but rather you
delve into these books okay so all of
these books in here
their first students are one grade level
appropriate but then second kind the
second best thing on the topic and
teachers have at their disposal further
their own learning in their own
knowledge okay the the best books okay
and they pull those in right and these
have the these books have the details in
it they little anecdotes and stories
they get to the heart of the matter
okay they have unique observations that
you're not going to get from a standard
textbook okay and they won the right
amount of emphasis generally in these
books if the author is emphasizing it
maybe that's a good thing for for you to
go into a little bit more with your
students as well
right and while you're doing these
research and you can look online as well
documentaries you know and using the B
CSI team as as as resources okay
looking to look to bring the lesson
alive right
keep in mind what our goals are here
wonder and representing those pasts past
so that they so the students can
experience that wonder okay
so a brief example you know they're in
the Cornell there's a Benedict Arnold
obviously turncoat during American
Revolution goes over to the side of the
British there's a there's a little town
up in up in New England that has that
has a statue a monument to Benedict
Arnold swag I have to give this this
this is a missus pries out go and view
Classical Academy go in Colorado this is
this is something that she happened upon
and developed but they the leg is there
because he was wounded before he had
been betrayed he was or before he
betrayed the the colonists and he was
wounded in the leg and so this the
statues to the only part of Benedict
Donald that was faithful to the cause of
the American Revolution that story is
not going to be in the core knowledge
student readers as good as they are and
they are good okay that's a story that
the teacher did their own research on
and many of these books will help with
that and but those types of things are
what engaged students and bring bring
them alive in the class all right so so
step one okay is to learn learn and know
the story yourself okay using the
program guide the student text and then
doing some research and using the books
at that Hillsdale College has outlined
us as strong for strong resources for
teachers as as the first resource that
you can go to alright after this first
step of crafting the lesson I learning
and knowing the story yourself step two
is actually crafting that story okay and
crafting is an artist and I'm and
perhaps I'll just lead off with this
look if you want to imagine yourself as
a movie director
directing a movie about these scenes
that can be a very helpful okay as
thinking about the types of details that
you should be sharing with students but
remember you're doing it with your own
words telling a story right so so in
these are these are some things to think
about in this second step now in grades
K through K through sixth or are these
focus questions or big questions at the
beginning of lessons those it can be
very helpful but in general have in mind
even if it's not stated to students in
the older grades let's say um have in
mind a daily focus question that you
want to that you want to share with
students and have them wrestle with
think about what those things are that
you want them to wonder at that you
wonder that yourself in your own
research what your own things that you
are finding interesting and pursuing
what those direct your lesson okay set
the stage you know every story takes
place in a certain place every movie has
a setting and have think about the
setting okay think about the climate the
weather the time of day the landscape
think about the rooms in which people
are working in the time period what they
would have been like okay what would be
liked to the census what does that smell
like sound like what smells do you have
okay what do you see okay what are the
feelings of things okay and then think
about the characters and their character
development think about your biography
star backgrounds their childhoods their
their temperaments their virtues and
vices or tendencies their hopes and
dreams and struggles okay think about
these things and do the research on them
pull it out set the stage for the
students keep an eye on individuals on
biography okay focus on people okay
particular people is they have whole
swathes of a country okay unless it's
appropriate to do so right so but keep
in people we really well to individuals
and it is a human story okay these are
just forces happening these are things
that individuals came to believe in act
consider a plan for Socratic questions
this can it's a very simple thing to do
but in our and our earnestness to share
with students and to share our passion
for our subjects with with our students
okay oftentimes you can blow right
through opportunities for students to
have to answer the question themselves
or for us to ask them those deeper level
questions like why and how and can you
explain that um so right some of those
into your lessons or keep a whole sheet
of them on your podium or something like
that so they're right there
okay be asking students questions
throughout the story and give them
opportunities to work through just work
through the thinking um consider primary
sources not every grade level is going
to use prime as many primary sources or
in the same ways you know the variety of
types from those they're first-hand
accounts to documents speeches all of
those sorts of things so but consider
them see if there's something that we
can pull in even if it's just quotes we
woven through this story okay those are
great ways now great ways to bring it
alive now there are opportunities for
the characters to speak right we use
some speaking for them but we're
possible let them speak for themselves
next and this is very important
incorporate maps and images into the
history lesson
this is a great opportunity to use quote
quote technology in classical education
images are great there's so many of them
and we have a lot of them available on
box comm right right there they they
help students to form the the story in
their minds of all ages okay um use maps
beautiful maps accurate maps maps that
you can ask them questions about what
ask that let them let them observe
things in the images ask them questions
about what they see and what they think
that might mean images are excellent
opportunities for Socratic questions
okay the one the one thing to keep in
mind however is is to make sure that
you're introducing the
or that when you're doing the planning
in the crafting that you're telling them
about the thing before you show them a
picture of it and I'll talk about more a
little bit more about that in a moment
um then finally when you have these
different elements weave it all together
imagining yourself first you should have
been able to imagine the story on your
own as you're crafting it how it's going
to play out what you're going to say
when and where how you're going to say
it which questions what images you're
going to show right this is intricate
okay this is the crafting of it that
that I had been mentioning and then
finally for the for the younger grades
kindergarten through fourth grade or so
considered an activity that's going to
help deepen that understanding okay
consider assignments for all grades
levels but make sure the assignments
actually helpful it's not just busywork
or something to for it for them to do so
that's there's an overview of how we
make crafts the lesson right and bring
it in and in such a way that is engaging
for students okay so that's the planning
side if you're doing this just the night
before that that makes sense
particularly if it's a first year of
teaching this content and end in this
way right but this is the type of of
craftsmanship that that has asked of us
if we're going to teach really strong
history lessons now part three the the
Performing side of it performing the
west notice I didn't want to use deliver
or presents or anything like that
perform that's because there is a good
bit of engagement and acting that the
teacher will do okay but I want to make
sure I qualify those statements so let's
see here right performing the lesson be
a storyteller um don't be a long-winded
lecturer okay alright tell the story and
tell it the way that you would direct in
a movie we'd your troops into it bring
them in okay ask them straight out to
ask them to use their imagination
right how have them have some skin in
the game be involved in this be dramatic
be vivid be emotional okay well the
entire time having a certain gravitas
okay so certain seriousness to it this
is serious stuff yes there are fun
moments so we should highlight those and
everything and have the right jovial
spirit for that but but have have some
weightiness to it
it's all its have some gravitas you're
on the stage think in terms of heroes of
being on the edge of your seats
riveted captivating in awe and wonder it
should be inspiring imaginative okay
okay students should be going on recess
I wanted to play games based on these
topics they should be wanting to read
books on it wanting to be a storyteller
a history teacher themselves something
okay then will they all want to know but
that's we shouldn't cut ourselves short
and pretend that that's not possible
right so be a storyteller and that means
build suspense in chronology okay have
some suspense to it the and when it
comes to the chronology that just means
tell us a story don't jump around if you
don't have to and certainly don't give
things away don't spoil the ending okay
and this is unfortunately something that
comes up somewhat frequently in telling
a history a story in history a history
lesson is that we start giving away
what's about to happen no that's a great
way to ruin the story don't do that okay
um so for instance okay let's say
seventh grade history teaching about
World War the World Wars students start
asking question you know they they get
into Hitler they starts asking Oh what
is when is Hitler come along and all you
have to do as a teacher is I don't know
why Hitler all the only let's say this
is during World War one say all I know
of a Hitler is that there's this
Austrian soldiers serving in the German
army they made off Hitler he's a
corporal he's been and towards the end
of the war he's been injured twice this
time with mustard gas he's recovering
his sight in a German field hospital
don't give it away
or what do we get to talk about World
War two like I don't know what you're
talking about right now we're worrying
about the Great War right it's it wasn't
called World War one by the people who
were living in it and we want to make
this current events to them they call it
the Great War and then once we do
eventually get to World War two and we
rename the Great War World War one okay
so keep that chronology in mind and
everything your notes and the lesson and
the tests and everything and then here's
where we go it back to catching students
interest and we already touched upon a
little bit why we don't want to catch
students interest with current events
now look if something overlaps with
current something going on today
naturally and it comes up in the class
that's that's fine that makes it just
don't let it make it drive to the lesson
okay but then the other two things that
we talked about was letting it be
research driven student research or
student interest driven now for one we
don't want it to be research driven
because students don't have enough of
the picture to to dive deeper into it
with their own research okay some of
highway skewed view of what the history
is right they need they need to have a
broader broader understanding and have
grappled with a little bit more before
we go let them go diving into their own
research especially in the younger
grades but secondly we don't want it to
be student interest driven we want to
catch students interest with the content
with the story that we're telling that's
what should be driving it you know what
the teachers who sometimes do say well I
just need to catch your interest somehow
and I need a relate to them it needs to
be something that it's connected to
their personal lives okay and I would
say two things one I I'm not sure if you
know if it's important to you if you
care about you see the Wonder in it then
that's the only thing you're going to
want to weed with that's the only thing
you want to take time for because it's
so important you can't take time for it
for what the students would would take a
straw poll on what they want to study
no we these it there's something missing
there the teacher needs to have a
different experience within and do more
to to learn and know and to wonder
and what they're teaching okay but then
secondly is that um students students
have enough of their own world and it's
the same thing with literature we want
to transport them to another world well
broaden their horizons okay we want to
take them to someplace else where they
forget about their current lives and
their whole lives and whatever else
they're gonna be all good things going
on at home and that's that's excellent
but there can also be some bad things
let's let's take them to another world
another time in place okay meet
introduce them to new characters so we
want to catch students interest with
content this isn't touched on before but
we also want to catch the interest with
Socratic questioning okay these are good
questions it gets them thinking students
are engaged okay if we're peppering our
lessons with these and interspersing
them throughout and pausing to ask
questions and to ask those why questions
and how what do you think and why do you
think that kind of types of questions
keeps everybody engaged and then finally
some sort of uh I am not sure if this is
the right word for it or phrase but semi
acting you know one of the things that's
pretty popular in consumer education is
having students act things out to do
skits right so it usually looks like is
that you pair off or you go into a group
and and you have a class period to sit
down and come up with a skit about about
you know the relationship between or
with Washington Crossing the Delaware or
something like that and and then we come
back together and each group presents
the scanner eats produce something
different and you know at best there's
some understating there because you want
them to be accurate but what's more
engaging and doesn't use nearly as much
time and probably cultivates more
understanding is that as the teacher is
presenting in the class and this is
particularly for the for the younger
grades but to say okay so here's Trenton
okay here's the Delaware River
here's Washington's camp okay now you
you and you I want you to be Washington
as men and in your boats and there's big
chunks of ice on the river it's cold
it's Christmas night and you're getting
ready to cross to attack these
mercenary soldiers is pressure that's on
the other side and if you're the
Prussians it's Christmas and what are
you thinking you're thinking nobody's
gonna attack on Christmas it's cold the
river has a current in there we've been
we've been taking care of the Americans
quite well without much trouble we're
gonna we're gonna settle down for a good
Christmas celebration write it have them
over there and and so what what I'm
saying is that you bring in you you can
get them some students how their seats
especially the students that have a
little bit of hard time paying attention
maybe or if I mean find things a little
more it's all get them evolved like that
and ask them questions as they're doing
it right as their as their acting some
of stuff out or given that perspective
of it alright so you know do incorporate
those types of things
okay into the into the classroom okay um
this is why I mentioned earlier share
maps and images and this is really
important for students engage them with
these ask them questions about them
however make sure that they that they
are encountering these after you've
talked to them about the characters and
the places describe it for them first
because when you do that you're allowing
them to imagine the entire scene on
their own it doesn't know what one it's
very enjoyable for students to be able
to do that and then - okay they they're
practicing and having your imagination
developed okay and then they when they
see the real thing okay that what what
what Napoleon really looked like after
you've taken time to describe them then
they correct their their image and the
Lord in that process okay not to mention
that this also forces the teacher to not
get lazy about their descriptions or how
they are how they're going to present
things okay because if you know that you
have to describe Polian right but you
can't show them a picture quite yet but
you still want them to have a really
vivid image of that okay then you're
gonna you're gonna do some a little more
research in the Napoleon or you're gonna
think about the best way to present it
for them so they can they can understand
that okay and then finally we pull all
these things together the storytelling
bowing suspense okay
catching students interest with the
content questioning and semi acting in
these images and maps
and we're going for this to make this
past experience present to students
again and we want Wonder to be the
results set it up so that at the end of
the lesson
after several lessons that you weave
them you leave students on the edge of
their seats okay waiting for the next
thing to happen right when what I had a
good buddy of mine who he told me he's
like whenever I read books I always
leave off right when it's getting good
and now for me that makes no sense that
whatsoever right no you keep going he
goes no no you want to leave off because
then I'm motivated to come back to it
okay I want to go pick it up next I'm
thinking about in-between right
if I leave off had in a wall in the
story then then that's going to be hard
to want to go class or go go back to
that book same thing in class it's gonna
be hard you want to go back to the class
think about this is what the the best TV
series do right they leave you with a on
the edge of their seats any same idea
okay or okay if not on their edge of
their seats waiting for the what to find
out what happens then leave them in
quiet ponder it's because you've come to
the end of a lesson or the story and now
it's time for students to sit back and
say whoa you reflect a little bit and
think okay and maybe just maybe stay in
your seats a moment after the bell rings
because of that so that's where we want
to get them in the end okay that's the
that's the crafting of the story and
performing of a story and again that
presents a very different type of
experience for students one that they
will have each day okay for 13 years of
their education of the starting
kindergarten okay not to mention that
for the teacher it's just a sheer joy to
share that with the students and that's
where the educating Act happens thank
you very much